sign to cspan.org
shop
and click on book tv
william f buckley jr is founder of the
conservative journal national review and
host of the pbs debate program firing
line he sat down for a book notes
interview in 1993 to discuss happy days
we're here again a collection of
articles and speeches mr buckley will
also be featured this weekend on our
american writers series this program is
just under an hour
william f buckley jr on the cover of
your new book it says reflections of a
libertarian journalist you always called
yourself a libertarian
off and on uh as
as as i'm of course you know
something called the fusion movement uh
was encouraged by by me and by national
review during the late 50s the idea was
to
to point out to the straight
libertarians and to the conservatives
how much
they had
uh in common and how how effective the
symbiosis would be between them
so from time to time i stress the fact
that i'm conservative every now and then
that i'm a libertarian
and there's a certain amount of
libertarian well in in most of what i
write is a certain amount that is
oriented to does this augment or
diminish
human liberty
do i remember you saying
maybe when you ran for mayor of new york
that
this may not be you that as far as
you're concerned you're just soon that
you throw the garbage out the window and
let people pick it up and deal with it
rather than having the government deal
with it
no
no the the uh
well
your memory is of an exchange i had with
james baldwin
in
which
he was defending
the littering of the streets
on the ground that it was a form of
protest
against the city for not paying close
enough attention
and i said look
uh it it isn't very it is very helpful
to use that as a means of protesting
should i throw my garbage out of the
street when john lindsay walks down
since i don't think he's uh
he'd make a good mayor but so it was
really it was really just sort of a
rhetorical dust about
if somebody buys this book what do they
get
well they um
they get the best i can give them
um in various modes over the past eight
years i've
those those were very eventful years
because they covered the collapse of the
soviet union
they covered the the death of some very
important uh
people
plus a certain number of personal uh
episodes
what i do
assisted by my sister who served as the
editor was to attempt to
divide
into appropriate sections the moods in
which i write the first she calls
assailing where i'm rough on carl sagan
and jesse jackson mario cuomo teddy
kennedy lowell weicker
elizabeth taylor and so on
they're then
analyzing
specific problems
i hope
assuredly and then a section on
commenting a section on reflecting and
then uh uh ending up
celebrating and appreciating various
people
uh and
a sports activity or two so
it's it's a it's a wide-ranging
collection it's my
ninth
and the rest have been well received so
i hope this one will be
do do people ordinarily buy former
columns and former articles and stuff
like that when you put them in a kind of
a compendium like this
the operative wouldn't want you in your
questions ordinarily
and the answer is that ordinarily people
don't buy anything
unless they are a part of a hard
constituency robert ludlum can count the
day after tomorrow on selling four
hundred thousand five hundred thousand
copies of his new book
but um
if the publisher brings out your ninth
collection
that usually means that people bought
the first aid
what's the
what's this and numbers of books that
you've written to the fifth
of all those books which sold the best
the book that sold the best was the
second of my four sailing books called
atlantic high
and then the mystery books
all came in somewhere you know between
75 and 100
uh except the very last one
which came out shortly after the end of
the cold war and suffered uh i was a
casualty at the end of the cold war
and then then the others um
well every book i've written most of the
books i've been on the best solo list
which ones did you enjoy the writing
part of it the most
this is going to annoy you but i i
really don't like to write it's a
terribly hard work
i mean that may be one reason why i have
managed to develop
the facility to write quickly
uh uh if i had the same kind of
languorous pleasure in writing that my
younger brother has or they'd say
eudora welty has who just
gets up with a light in the eye saying
my god this is the day in which i
write
and then um i can answer your your
question with with a greater sense of
hedonism
george will once said to me i write
three times a week
when i wake up in the morning the first
question i subconsciously ask myself is
is this a day in which i have to write a
column and if the answer is affirmative
i wake up bright and happy
it happens exactly the reverse with me
do you then write
for an end instead of uh
i mean you're what are you trying to do
uh also also you know a lot of us
do things for the after pleasure of it
uh uh even
weeding your garden
for the after pleasure of seeing the
roses and the grass come up or practice
your scales for the after pleasure of
helping
to develop your technique
uh as wider containers once once put it
to me i like to have written
and that that's that's a nice thing to
have written in part because it is so
onerous other than the big names the
ones that would be obvious to ronald
reagan's and richard nixon do you know i
went through and counted so i think i
know this but do you do you know
which person you quoted the most or
talked about the most in this book no i
don't
would it surprise you if i said whitaker
chambers
well uh um you obviously um
surprised me uh that on the other hand
i'm wearing what you said whitaker
chambers
during the period where we were very
close friends which is about seven years
wrote me in fact he he wrote me uh such
beautiful letters that they were they
were published as a book
and uh he kept saying things in it that
were very arresting both in
what he said and in the way that he said
it as a matter of fact the novel i have
coming up next january uh one of the
high points in it
has to do with the discovery by young
young veterans of the afghan war uh in
moscow
of the description
by whitaker chambers in one of his
letters to me
of the narodniki
they were the group of young people
who
met silently
in the tsarist days and swore to give
their lives over
to the assassination of a of a tyrant
so lenin celebrated the narod nikki as
uh whitaker team has pointed out but
then discovered that they were pretty
dangerous because people could get the
same idea as being applicable to
lenin to to lenin and therefore all
trace of them was removed from soviet
literature so you had to turn to
political chambers to find out about
this enormously important and romantic
development in russian history
what kind of an impact did he have on
you and when did you know him and and
let me just throw in this one for
somebody that's never heard of him
who was he
well whitaker chambers
was the time magazine
senior editor
who in sworn testimony
named people he had known
while working as a secret intelligence
agent for the soviet union
and one of those was aldra hirse
they ensued the greatest ongoing
division
i guess in american cultural history on
the question of who was lying the
evidence is pretty overwhelming that the
person was lying is out of his who is
still alive by the way
but we we we became uh friends in 1954
and he became actually
uh a formerly a and a seniority of
national review though he came up very
infrequently and he died at a very young
age 61 of a heart attack but he had an
enormous impact
when his book witness was written
they ran the first chapter which was a
letter to his children
uh the theme was that in which he said
when i left the soviet union
to left the communist cause to be to
join the cause of the west
i couldn't help but feeling that perhaps
i was leaving the winning side to join
the losing side
so there was that that uh
that great um
sense of melancholy in much of his
writings
i was about to point out that they
serialized the first
chapter of his book the legislature in
the saturday evening post
and sold 500 000 more copies than normal
so it had a huge impact on everybody who
read it and uh from that uh moment on he
became something of an american legend
and probably still is
so i don't think any
quotation of him
is likely to
bring on tedium in the reader
i saw a reference a couple of months ago
to the fact that in august of 1948
in that hearing that it was the first
ever televised hearing
i didn't know that the alger has the
hugh active house on american activities
committee i i want to go back to that to
ask you
what empi richard nixon was on that
committee
yes he was
as a matter of fact that was um
that was the first episode in nixon's uh
in nixon's career
that
gave me an enormous launch
because the committee was a little bit
dazzled
by the firepower of the pro-his forces
and they were about to pull away and say
hiss was right and chambers is a liar
when
nixon moved in
and mobilized the evidence and uh
persuaded the congressional committee
that in fact his was probably lying not
chambers so he became very conspicuous
during that period
and
it was that
that gave him the
reputation that
awarded him a seat in the senate in
in the senate uh two years later and two
years after that the vice president of
the united states where were you then
well he was elected he was elected vice
president 1952 and i graduated from
college in 1950
so i was sort of around but but uh the
the his chambers drama was a very
significant episode
when i was at school
uh liberals tended to assume that hiss
was correct
because his pedigree was so formidable
he had gone to johns hopkins then he'd
gone to the harvard law school then he
had clerked
with uh
uh with um
um
uh who was it
in the supreme court um the theme was
jewish
liberal frankfurter frankfurt yeah
and uh
then dean atterson had sort of testified
to the nobility of his character and all
this time
he was typing out secrets of the soviet
union with his wife priscilla uh his so
he was a tremendous blow to the liberal
establishment that this
this shining legacy of the new deal
was in fact
a traitor
now most most people
who are identified with new deal
years ago conceded that that's what he
was arthur schlesinger for instance
but uh
some people are still hypnotized with
the subject of his sort of like the
grassy knollers on jfk
it's more fun to believe that there was
a
conspiracy beneath the conspiracy
do you remember
back in those years who and who was
influencing you the most
back what you went to yale i was here
yeah well you know i had a few
professors who you probably wouldn't
have heard of who who were influential
uh i've always found it hard to find to
answer the question to influence you the
most because uh it seems to me that
in
retrospect
it is a kind of a collage of
people and it's very hard to sort out
what it was that uh influenced you in
respect of this particular thing
i my colleague for 25 years nationally
was james burnham
who was probably the best
known american
geophysical strategist by training a
philosopher first in this class in
princeton so on and he influenced me
enormously
but i didn't meet him until the magazine
began what year does the magazine begin
55.
in the back of
your book
there are
it's the section in which you
it's called appreciating
and a number of people that you write
about
are no longer alive
let me pick a couple of these
some of them are alive and ask you about
them sure um
malcolm muckridge who wasn't
well
malcolm mugler's was
i think it's probably safe to say the
best-known
british journalist up until 10 15 years
ago
he was married to the niece of beatrice
webb and he went to the soviet union as
sort of a committed young
socialist pro-communist
and
he was there
for about one winter and wrote a
devastating critique
of um
life under stalin this was in the early
30s
uh he still stayed over pretty much on
the socialist side of the world he he
wrote industriously for the manchester
guardian and others in several books
then during the war he was uh very
active and then after the war he was the
editor of punch magazine
uh one had to be sort of a humorous to
do that plus a very skillful journalist
meanwhile he was simultaneously editing
the book section for esquire magazine
but little by little by little he
began
a march that would turn out to be
ineluctably
directional towards
damascus
he became
a christian
and
his perspective changed but not
his idiomatic powers
so that when he was talking about uh
christ or about
the commandments or about
our duty to one another
he would manage to do so
as a humorist
uh and uh it under the circumstances
gave a kind of a a lift
to his evangelism that was quite
distinctive i saw him believe it or not
speak to the aas and the american
society of newspaper editors in
washington the editor of every principal
newspaper in the united states
and um
it was you know he was just the after
dinner speaker
and and uh
he ended up with a paragraph
that um
that embellished the idea of the meaning
of the star over bethlehem
and had
these
pagans
absolutely stupefied
by the sheer beauty of it so so anyway
he he became the um
probably the most influential english
speaking
uh intellectual how was it
um he was on fine line
uh actually uh quite a lot of times
at seven or eight times and we became
very close personal friends about that
he and i once did a program in in the
vatican
uh on the sistine chapel
and he
he called up said you know
i hate famous people i've known them all
and they're always a disappointment but
i want to meet this pope
so i said well you crank up your muscle
i crank up mine so
he and i and david niven and my wife had
an audience a private audience with the
pope which is very amusing because
the pope hadn't been briefed on who we
were
so when he came to malcolm ugland he
looked at him with that sort of benign
face this is the current pope the
current pope yeah i said ah
you are
radio
now
however often you ask yourself the
question what is the appropriate answer
to you are radio it's hard hard to come
up with one so uh
malcolm just margaret said you're yes
sir you're homeless i i do some amount
of work on video then you turned to
david nevin said ah
you were the great friend of my
predecessor now dear david had probably
never even heard of pope paul iv the vi
but uh
you know it quickly became plain that
the pope thought we were visiting
basketball managers or something
anyway muggers was
vastly amused by that uh episode do you
know who you were
no but i thought i'd tip him off because
here we had access to the sistine chapel
the first time in history
as a result of an intermediary who had
gotten permission for us to use it for
48 hours to make our documentary
so i thought i'd tip him off so i said
your wholeness
it's going to be very hard for me to get
used to my private traffic when i get
home after having had access to yours
thinking you get it
thinking that would flash back but he
was so alarmed by what i said that he
sort of snapped his fingers and the
monsignor showed up the pictures were
taken and
we said goodbye
but anyway after that the margaret said
to me
i want to do a show with you
called why i am not a catholic i said
fine
so we did it and he gave all the reasons
why he wasn't catholic
and two years later he called me up and
said i want to do another show with you
i said what why i am a catholic
he had
he had poked as they say in england
in the interval
he was a he was a wonderful wonderful
wonderful man a great wit and a
brilliant brilliant analyst i want to
ask you about a quote that you put in
your column about it by the way when you
how often do you write about
no i'm sorry with an rip after to rest
in peace do you often do that um i do it
a fair amount yeah uh i've been doing it
for national review for years and years
and years
i mean i don't know how many i've done
maybe 500 or
i don't know
um with this i'm not an obituary writer
i mean that's not my profession
but it does it is there some way to
describe what it takes to get you to
write about write somebody's obituary i
mean
do you have to like them
uh or dislike them
one one or the other um or they had to
have been a friend of a national viewer
of mine or or have had some historical
uh or importance uh when i was editor of
my own journal i would
i wrote about them when i assigned them
when now that donald sullivan is the
editor i write them when he asks me to
and when i agree to do so
and occasionally i write send one out as
a regular column
as i did in the case of luggage and i
don't know whether maybe he's the only
one here that i set out as a column let
me just read you this quote and ask you
whether you agree
as an old man this is malcolm muggeridge
as an old man bill looking back on one's
life
it's one of the things that strikes you
most forcibly that the only thing that's
taught one anything is suffering not
success not happiness not anything like
that the only thing that really teaches
one what life's about the joy of
understanding the joy of coming into in
contact with what life really signifies
is suffering
but let me answer let me comment on that
by saying two things number one i
understand the historical discipline
that caused him to write that way it is
you know the lesson of job
that job
taught us
that
suffering
can be uh ennobling
and in the case of malcolm muggeridge
he he seemed to feel that impulse
properly but it may have been it may
have been part of his velcro there was a
certain sense in which uh his sort of
gloom
about um about the materialism of man
and uh man's failure
to
to be
uh inspired
uh by um
to be inspired by
that particular part of our patrimony
that should inspire us
cause him to feel that the
an expiation of thoughts was in order
for instance he became a vegetarian and
he didn't drink any booze any wine or
anything it didn't used to be that way
but one one had a sense that he was
taking some sort of a
pleasure
from the
mortification of the flesh
and that but that pleasure never
affected his mood
to john lennon's introduction
in thinking back on his days of national
review says
he's listing the various things he did
he said i had lunch with whitaker
chambers which was like lunching with
the brothers karamazov
and
although
it's incorrect to say whitaker chambers
that he emanated melancholia when you
were with him it's not incorrect to say
about him that you you felt the
palpability
of uh of his melancholy with margaret
you didn't
a mogridge was a consistent entertainer
uh without in any way
getting in the way of his own message
do you feel that people expect you to
entertain them all the time
um
well
i think it's a terrible sin
to bore people
and um
i'm easily bored myself
um
i mean i'm perfectly prepared to to
admit that if i attended our lecture by
emanuel can't i might very well go to
sleep
but that's my fault not his
so under the circumstances when i write
i i do make an effort
to please the reader
in the same way that um
a pianist that
had a
dive or what
wants to use chords
that please the
listener
if if you are
if you sit down
to play a musical repertoire and limit
yourself to a dominant a subdominant
and a
tonic
you're never going to give music the
kind of uh
variety
that uh
makes it so special
by the same token it seems to me that if
you deny yourself uh
the the the hard work and at the same
time the pleasure
of using the language um
exploitatively
you shouldn't really be writing uh
professionally
you've got a bunch of letters also in
here letters that have been sent to you
and yeah uh dear mr buckley this is from
hamilton morgan of harrison new york
regarding your firing line interview
with henry kissinger from a qualified tv
professional objectively concerned
american colon
number one
the manner in which you sit is rude
you remember this no
can't you sit upright in an adult
fashion
in single shots you appear tilted
in two shots you sit as if your guest
has
bo
two even in questioning you appear rude
you don't ask questions of a guest even
one whose opinions you favor but your
questions come in a long form of
interrogation
three you always come up with the
personal insecurity of a long preface
attempting to show that what
you know
you answer him
first thing he says no i can't think
straight congenital
you on but
when you get a letter like this first of
all uh
what was my comment what is your what is
your comment uh most people don't talk
about it out loud if you think my
questions are long try socrates three of
course i want to share what i know about
the subject after all i spent three
hours reading up on it at night before
have you ever jumped out of an airplane
at midnight with a parachute question
mark with the mission of eliminating the
guard at the end of the bridge well i
haven't either but if i did i would
certainly want detailed
introductory instructions and on and on
oh well i i guess i took it more
seriously than i
remember having done so
um
having brought the subject up which you
just did i don't usually appear on
television dressed this way but i
i just finished a 2 000 mile hike
so i asked your permission not to have
to go and change and you kindly gave it
to me
the answer is
we all have our idiosyncrasies but uh he
he's absolutely wrong on point five and
and point six because uh
uh in
my my program has been going on for 29
years it's the longest running program
with the same host in america
i don't i
have one complaint in those 29 years
from my guests
that i didn't give them all the time
they wanted to say in the way they
wanted what they wanted to say so that's
not bad number two
on the matter of introducing
the guests since i often have people who
are not widely known
philosophers or or poets or whatever
i feel an obligation
to acquaint the listener
with them
and
if you take a couple minutes to do that
i don't think that's inordinate
especially back when the program was one
hour
rather than the half hour it is now when
you get a letter like this what's your
first reaction do you smile or do you
well when i get the first thing i ask
myself is is this the letter i should
publish in national review where i have
a column called called notes on the
sides
which is a column of letters directed to
me which are either instructive or
bellicose or uh interesting in whatever
way
uh in in in
in respect of the one you just read me
obviously my reaction was
i ought to tell this guy a couple of
things
plus also i shouldn't shield from my
readers the fact that some people
react this way this with that kind of
hostility
to everything from my comportment to my
behavior on my own program here's
another one you wrote this letter and
this was to the editor of the baltimore
sun by the way on these letters did did
your sister pick all these herself she
nominated them in the yeah
and i okay or didn't okay
you say uh
and you're you're commenting on what the
baltimore sun said in an editorial about
using
and then you write you're talking to the
baltimore sun william f buckley jr whose
elegant arrogance
first of all do you think you have
elegant arrogance
is this a quote from them from them
an affectations of a british accent has
won him fame and fortune
well that's kind of dumb because of the
people with a fake british accent don't
necessarily have fame and fortune do
they
you go on to say at the end here
arrogance and affectations being
separate modifiers they require the use
of a plural verb so you were shooting
back at the editor
oh yeah
well
uh is that all i said yes well yeah
there's some stuff earlier than that but
that was that i just wanted to ask you
when you people
write you in and talk about the you know
the tilt and your
your presence on the set or your
so-called affectation of everybody's
accent
do you know that that's the way you look
to people well uh somewhere maybe in
this book or somewhere i said look um
up until age six i spoke only spanish
that was the only language i spoke then
i went to my first school in paris
where of course they spoke french
then at age seven i went to london and
that's where i learned english for the
first time
now what all i had to sound like you
tell me uh so that's that's uh
it's
incidentally no nobody who's british
thinks i have a british accent
so it's it's just um
occasionally people say to me in
minnesota where are you from i see i'm
from connecticut
and they they say well they think that
well maybe that's how they speak in
connecticut
but uh um
there's nothing cultivated my accent as
my
family and friends would tell you
what were you doing in all those places
well my father was uh
in the oil business
and he had very large families so he had
a
mexican
he was bilingual himself and he had um
he had a family staff who spoke french
or spanish how many brothers and sisters
did you have ten how many of them are
alive
seven
i was a six
and you have a brother that's a federal
judge
he was senator
from new york he was beaten by moynihan
in 76.
do you you ran for mayor once and lost
do you wish that you had won
no i i didn't uh
i didn't run thinking that i would would
win i ran under the conservative label
which up until then the most that they
ever got was one and a half percent
so i got uh
13 percent
my my my joke
made for the benefit of people who
teased me about having them so poorly is
that i think if you're running for may
of new york and you get 13 it's
dangerously close to winning so that if
i were to win again my
campaign slogan would be voting by
invitation only
what's uh what's your life like today
you're no longer running the national
review no
i don't know no longer the edit of
national view but i'm the president of
the board
and the
owner
and i
rejoice every day that john o'sullivan
is such a brilliant editor uh i have a
book
about what you're discussing in a novel
coming out in january and i'll write
another one in switzerland
i have a piece coming out in the 40th
anniversary of playboy and one in the
60th anniversary of esquire i'm
reviewing a 1600 page travel book by
henry james for the new york times so i
and i lecture a lot so so i keep busy
where do you live
it's time for connecticut
where do you spend most of your time
we're there and on boats and then
traveling around but my wife and i go to
switzerland
that's where i do my book writing in
february and march
and how long do you plan to do firing
line
well put this right i don't plan not to
do it
so uh
so it presumably it will continue to go
on as long as it serves a purpose
has um the fact that the the firing line
is on a public television network tax
support ever
bothered you in in relationship to your
politics
no because um
i came to terms
very early
with the proposition that
a minority in a democracy lives by the
rule of the majority
and even if i wanted to see the post
office privatized
i'm not going to protest it by not using
the facilities of the post office
on this uh
i agree 100 with milton friedman
and and as recently as um
a few years as as a few months ago
he uh wrote a letter to national review
agreeing with the position i took
over against and a former editor of
national view who hadn't wanted to take
social security because he was opposed
to the social security law
and his his answer was no
social security was voted in
continue to criticize that aspect of it
that you think is wrong or how it's run
but to fail to participate in it
is
is a failure
to
live by
the verdict of a
majority
which
dominates which one's a republic in
which
you are a participant and whose rules
you agreed to abide by unless
they become tyrannical
has national review ever made any money
no
no no i don't know if any journal of
opinion has ever made money
with perhaps the exception of the new
republic when it was the house organ of
the progressive citizens of america
which was then a fellow traveling outfit
designed to make henry wallace president
of the united states
journals of opinion um
tend not to make money though we're
doing better than ever ever before how
do you keep it going then through an
annual fund appeal
plus uh
plus directing certain amount of my own
uh income in this direction
back to the back of the book again uh
william shawn
gee this is a column january the 18th
1993 or
it was i assume public published
national review
who was william shaw well well william
sean became the editor of the new yorker
in 1953
right after mr ross died
and he was its editor for about 35 or
35 years up until three or four years
ago
he was a man of spectacular talent and
of of
very idiosyncratic personal uh manners
he was
terrifyingly shy
and
um
are very reclusive
enormously uh uh uh well organized
and
when i sent a manuscript
of a
book in which i simply recounted what i
had done during a week
of that year
and he accepted it
for publication i couldn't believe it
because i'm a conservative and the new
yorker is pretty liberal what year is
this this was 1970
so then i
sent him a second book and he accepted
it and then a third book and accepted it
then a fourth book and then a fifth book
so that um
i had this extraordinary hospitality by
this uh by this
extraordinary man now about once a year
he assigned himself the job of editing
line by line a book that had been
accepted by the new yorker
and it felt to me
to fall under his personal uh uh uh
under his personal direction for the
first of these books which meant having
a lunch with him
having lunch with william shawn
uh was uh
uh well
[Music]
the next thing to a declaration why
because you thought that you were
getting the way of his
privacy
and he was very formal and and very very
genius always mr buckley i mean he
wouldn't think of calling me by my by my
first
name but it was an enormous experience
because of the care and love that he
devoted to every
single sentence
he once said to me
mr buckley i really don't think that you
know the proper use of a comma
enormously amused me
and and it's true that takes certain
liberties and uses the karma intending
certain effects
which uh
every now and then just made him but he
would never publish anything except
after your approval of exactly the way
it appeared he was very fastidious on
that point
so my association with him was was
wonderful
and then when he retired
as our recount in this obituary
i thought
gee was now he's no longer
a man who's sort of in charge of my
literary fortune
shall i ask him to lunch
i would never have asked him to lunch
while he was still editor so i did and
he accepted
so we we we had a lunch then
another year go by i thought now shall i
ask him for lunch again the arguments
against doing it
are you know respect his privacy the
arguments for doing it are that i might
by having had lunch with him just one
time
have given me the impression that i was
discharging an obligation
and now thank god having distorted i
could let him go ahead and rusticate
so i did
and he accepted but didn't make a date
and then i received the day that he died
a letter that he'd written me the day
before
making pleasant references to a couple
of books that sentence
so he was he was an unusual
man who had an enormous influence on the
american letters
and a great patron of people like john
updike whom he discovered did you also
say that he would call up months in
advance and with your secretary and
check that make sure that wait when
you're trying to get a date set he's
well we'd better do that off a couple
months from now i mean
at the end yeah he he loved
he loved to talk to your secretary as
distinguished from speaking with with
you
and he would almost be almost be by his
standards informal with the secretary
uh but he would
he would say oh yes i would like very
much to have lunch mr buckley uh uh and
and and i i will call back and suggest
today to see if it's all right with him
that kind of stuff
and uh he wasn't all shy about talking
with the secretary but was much more
reluctant to call you
you have a tribute in the back here
under the appreciating section to nancy
and ronald reagan and at some point i
think i remember you writing about their
their dancing together
you remember that
well that was a piece i i did for vanity
fair
and they ran it on the cover a picture
they got an interview with the reagans
tina
brown
and uh
the interviewer this was in the private
quarters of the white house they'd only
been there a couple years and said uh
would you consent to dance for us
meaning for the photographer
and instantly he said of course
so the music went on and they they
started to dance the photographer took
his pictures thinking he had he'd have
15 seconds to do it but they just kept
on dancing
and you know vanity fair isn't used to
situations like that where the president
united states and his uh
and his wife
dances so they had
just exchanged
a commitment to marry each other but
that's that's the way they are and
nobody who has seen it close up
thinks it's it's phony uh it isn't phony
it's a case of perpetual abiding
devotion
and another and i'm just looking at i
underlined it um as i mentioned earlier
the one the name that i saw the most
often was whitaker chambers it's in that
piece where you say
the last time i heard the legend of
uh philemon and is it bocas
seriously was in the final paragraphs of
whitaker chambers book witness
chambers was given to melodrama but
those who knew him and his wife esther
never doubted that it was so between
them
uh it's such a beautiful story isn't it
you want to read it or you want me to
say go ahead yeah
well um
a god i feel
it would be a greek god
dressed like a
beggar
appears in this humble little shed
where this old couple are looking
uh with
some longing at the little porridge that
they have saved to eat that night and he
says can he have something to eat
without hesitation
they
take half of it and give it to him
where upon having
tested their capacity for charity
he
he uh
transfigures himself and he they see
that he is the resplendent god
uh and in whitaker chambers phrase he
raises his caduceus which is
with the great imperial staff and says
tell me
what one wish you desire
and they stammer out the wish that they
wish
to die at the same
time no one wants to outlive the other
so with his caduceus he touches them on
the head
and suddenly they are transformed into
two trees
which
which uh nestle
together are in the breeze
and
leave the impression of
a continuing perpetual symbolism
of um a a tender and beautiful love it's
it's a beautiful story
theodore white teddy white
well
teddy white uh
[Music]
once said to me you know i'm probably
the most expensive
journalist in america
and i said well that's that's terrific
he said well you know as you know i
don't like to both but it's probably
true
it's about 10 15 years ago and i i think
it's probably correct
he was the most sought after journalist
and for several reasons one he was a
terrific writer
a second he was a
terribly industrious reporter
he three he knew everybody
he also had a capacity
to make you
talk to him and say things that
probably you weren't really predisposed
to tell him
he had that that
extraordinary quality bob woodward has
the same uh gift
so well anyway teddy fry was sent by
life magazine to do
a piece on john lindsay when he was
running for mayor which required him to
do a piece also on me
at the same time because i was running
for mayor
and
so uh he he came to see me
and i
said something pleasant to him he said
first business we'll be we'll become
friends later
and we became very good friends in fact
we
we both
followed nixon to china we were two of
the journalists who went to uh china in
1972 and spent a lot of time together
and he and i and three or four other
friends met always six seven times a
year for lunch so he was a dear
wonderful talented human being
he came from a very poor jewish ghetto
in uh
in boston which he liked to write about
was sort of worked his way through
harvard
became a sinologist was entranced by mao
zedong for a while
something a little bit of a fellow
traveler on the chinese question
saw the light of day a few years later
was very very high up in the loose
organization very close friend of henry
news but then they had a ideological
parting of the ways
so he had he had a very vivid wonderful
uh productive life what do you mean by
fellow traveler
well he um
he tended to think that everything that
mao zedong came up with was probably
correct i'm talking about
the late 30s and uh early 40s during the
period when chiang kai-shek was sort of
withering on the vine
and there was a lot of
uh corruption
but uh his his uh
his uh
hospitality
to the
mouse movement alienated henry luce was
very fervently on the other side and
caused that
uh that resignation
well we're used to to seeing you play
bach at the phoenix symphony and uh
we're right about bach but in this
appreciating section
uh you you have a column is beethoven a
monument what what what's that all about
well that's a very interesting point the
uh
adam smith said that the state can
legitimately do certain things and those
are a very short list
it can look after the common defense
and it can
be the custodian
of monuments
so
i asked myself the question
does the
authority
of adam smith attach
to a state
enterprise
that
takes dead musicians
and makes their music available i had
specifically in mind
something that happens in switzerland in
switzerland for about like a buck a
month or whatever it is
you can plug your telephone line in to
six channels and one of those channels
if you push button number three has
nothing but classical music day and
night
uh
it is uh simply a marvelous amenity
so i was trying to
i was trying to manipulate conservative
orthodoxy in such a way as to suggest
that
a monument need not only be something
chiseled and marble sitting in the
middle of a park
but might also be
keeping alive
a
musician
and providing the
the wonderful amenity of access to him
cheaply
all the things you do in in the public
speak
uh
interview on television
being interviewed
writing books writing columns
what's the
what brings the most fun and joy to you
and what's the most difficult
well what brings i suppose the the most
and the easiest pleasure is um
assailing
i say a lot
and i've done it since i was 13 years
old and uh it's um
to me a
marvelous marvelous form of recreation
but it is recreation i used to ride a
lot when i was a boy but i don't know
that anymore
in terms of what's most difficult
there is nothing for me as difficult
as trying to uh master
a piece of music on the hopscotch in
part because i have very bad fingers
they don't behave well
and they are insufficiently disciplined
but about in a more public policy area
like
the the things like
would you rather be interviewed or would
you rather do the interviewing
i think it probably depends on the
person
sometimes one has a guest
who monfils one ought to have on
because um
he's onto something important that we
want to talk about
but he might be an awfully boring human
being
and uh after one hour you you sort of
swear you're sweatily glad that it's
over
by contrast uh
uh are now with some people i think for
instance of uh
harold macmillan
uh
at the end of 42 minutes he said i say
aren't we through yet
and i said no we have 17 more minutes to
go very well we're probably talking more
marvelous stories about what you said to
church you know what churchill said the
headlines answered so that was that was
a sheer joy so i think it depends
completely on the person
uh
an interview
by somebody who really doesn't follow
what you're saying
is hell
because you feel that you have explained
something
and and the next question
absolutely establishes that they have
the remotest idea what you said or if
they heard it they didn't understand it
and that's that's that that hurts
sometimes
people who have okay they have 30
questions when i asked mr buckley so
they asked question number one
you you you give a reply to it but it's
a reply that
obviously takes you through act two not
act three of the exchange
but they don't know enough to lead you
into act three they go right to the next
question
and that shows that there's a
discontinuity there that makes the whole
thing terribly abrupt and unsatisfying
did you ever have anybody get up and
walk off the set
in fireline
no no i think it's very bad manners to
do that uh you know unless uh
unless someone engages
a profanity
or
i i can i could as a novelist i could
write a situation in which my
guy would walk off the set
and people would report him for doing so
but i've never walked in that situation
what year was it that you and john
kenneth galbraith
slugged it out on was it the total show
yeah well we did it we did it in 1972
and in 1976. as i remember and it's a
little bit a few years have passed that
you really got at each other yeah well
let me tell you something it was a very
interesting in 1972 we were in miami
we were there for both conventions but
we had 25 minutes
and in 25 minutes you can get a certain
amount done by 1976 all the format in
the morning news shows had changed
and and to have more than seven minutes
you had to
a meeting of the board of directors so
in seven minutes
neither of us could unwind
and
you know our specialty is not the
the johnny carson
jab
but something which to the extent that
it has a point
might require a minute
of analytical overture
and both of us agree that we simply
didn't work
uh
attempting to exchange
views in in seven minutes so we um we
never asked to do it again was that ever
personal though i mean people haven't
seen it they can't remember it but you
were
i remember you're saying some pretty
strong things oh yeah yeah um
the the
he he and i um
almost arrived at a mutual covenant that
because we were close personal friends
we were under those under no
circumstances going to permit that
friendship
to mitigate the harshness that we feel
for the other person's position i mean i
don't mind saying to him can
if you've been president of the united
states by now we'd have been a soviet
republic which is absolutely correct
and and he says complementary things
about my me
some conservatives have criticized you
for living um
in two different worlds they they i mean
i've seen various times in fact i think
i interviewed
bob terrell in his book where he talks
about a dinner or something he had up
here in new york with you
in which they when they criticize the
crusaders for being a pal of the
liberals
a pal of the liberals you go to
dinner with them and you
have lunch with them and you have
friends at the new york times and things
like that have you you've undoubtedly
observed these criticisms
what do you say to somebody that
criticizes you for for being friends
with us i i see in fact it's odd
because um
you you can you can disagree very
pointedly with somebody
and still having a enormous bond of
friendship cure curiously
this is absolutely routine in england
the the editor of the new statesman
nation
might be the godfather
of the
new child of the editor of uh
uh of um
uh
the tablet
there there's there's nothing there's
considered unusual
about a member of the labour party
remember the conservative party being
very close friends
and uh so i don't think that's uh
unusual
if uh to uh to have somebody with whom
you disagree
in the first place i don't spend my time
talking politics
i go to london tomorrow
i have to talk politics three days from
now because it's a political seminar but
i doubt very much between now and then
i'll talk about parts of anybody not to
my wife not to my host over there
because it's not the kind of thing that
interests me that much
there's other things to talk about that
uh
so that
in in i could spend time with ken
galbraith uh
as i have i always have to have
ourselves which politics political
things can never come up when they do
come up we just do it as sort of a form
of calisthenics what do you talk about
trollop
um
skiing
um
what he did
when he left uh
canada
and came over here as a scholar
or
there's nothing we don't talk about
there's no problem at all in the first
place when you talk with ken gabriel
mostly he talks
but
but he's so entertaining that one
doesn't mind
on the cover of your book and inside the
flap it's
an introduction by john leonard the same
john leonard that we see on cbs on
sunday morning
yes
isn't he a liberal
oh yeah very much very much everyone has
as he has the uh
what's the right word confesses
uh
when i when i started national review
i saw a magazine called ivy which i had
an essay
which was 1955
and there was an essay by him
by one john leonard so i called him up
because it was beautifully written
and said to him uh would he
like to
take a summer job with national review
he said i'll take a job anytime with
anybody since i've just been kicked out
of harvard
so he worked for us for a year and a
half uh did marvelous work then he went
off to um
berkeley to be radicalized
which was uh very completely done
but he's a brilliant brilliant um writer
and the acknowledgements in the
beginning we're just about out of time
um you say i'm indebted primarily to mrs
bozell senior editor of ragnary gateway
who is mrs bozell she's my sister
and she's a full-time uh editor for
regular gateway how did you publish my
first book oh i said that this is a
random house yeah she was doing just as
a friend or just i mean this is a
brother
sister yeah what are you saying here i
would not give out the date of the
declaration of independence without
first checking with her no with dorothy
mccartney oh i'm the chief chief
researcher at national review so i
was paying her a compliment that she's
uh owed
ah
other than the novel
that's coming out in january
what's next in non-fiction
in non-fiction
well i i'm about one-third of the way
through a book that i on on the catholic
uh
religion
which i suspended
because i didn't have enough time to do
the reading i thought i had to do
whether i will crank that up
or not i don't know
there are a couple of other ideas uh
floating about
which i haven't yet decided but i will
write a book though
happy days we're here again is the name
of the book it's reflections of a
libertarian journalist our guest william
f buckley jr thank you very much thank
you
happy days we're here again reflections
of a libertarian journalist is out of
print but you can visit an online
bookseller for purchase information
for an in-depth look at william f
buckley jr head for our companion
network c-span sunday at 3 p.m eastern
as our american writers series continues
live
next week on encore book notes an
examination of u s history from its
founding to its 50th anna